the custom pair of shoes that Joe Rogan
was wearing at the UFC weigh-ins last
weekend were made from the skin of one
of his favorite animals ever elk the
low-cut sneakers also included murals of
Joe Rogan's favorite authors artwork
inspired by his podcast and a real-life
archery target that was sewn into the
heel this is a Miyamoto Musashi like
style R it's like a canvas stuff and
samurai sword oh where I got that book
that's amazing it's supposed to be like
a pattern from like a bear a bear that's
amazing and then inside on the insole
there's like a bunch of Art and stuff
that's so cool aliens pyramids dude I'm
gonna wear these at the UFC weigh-ins
today